hi this is preshtalwalker in this video
i'm going to teach you how you can
remember the nine times table on your
fingers
to begin place your two hands in front
of you
and think about numbering the fingers
from one to ten starting with your left
hand
let's do an example of seven times nine
count over to the seventh finger which
is the index finger on your right hand
and bend that finger
to do the calculation we count the
number of fingers to the left of the
bent finger and to the right
there are six fingers to the left of the
bent finger and there are three fingers
to the right
seven times nine is therefore sixty
three
this is a great trick and will in fact
show you how you can do this for all of
the times tables from one to ten
for one times nine
we'll bend the first finger on our left
hand
now we count the number of fingers there
are zero fingers to the left of the bent
finger and nine fingers to the right so
one times nine is nine
for two times nine we bend the second
finger
there's one finger to the left and eight
fingers to the right to make eighteen
three times nine we bend the third
finger
we have two to the left and seven on the
right to make twenty seven
four times nine we'll have three on the
left six on the right to make 36
five times nine will have four
and five to make forty five
six times nine
has five and four
to make fifty four
seven times nine
is six and three
sixty-three
eight times nine
will be seven and two
seventy-two
nine times nine
is eight
one eighty one
and finally nine times ten we'll have
nine fingers to the left and zero
fingers to the right to make ninety
so we've done the entire nines tables
using just our hands and counting the
number of fingers so now you'll never
forget your nines table
i hope you like this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can get my
books on math there's a link in the
video description you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can also catch me on a bunch
of social media sites thanks for
watching
you